hello and welcome to this video playing
team glute yeah I ahead of 50 score
against him and then lost three games in
a row and I want something else then the
Italian game he always plays the Italian
and then somehow some I lose at the end
not quite sure why but I do so playing
something else here the reinventing that
opens the scien thinking 10 seconds to
move
hmm that's funny I mean it's not like
you have a choice here you can go to F
30 be three or something but it's really
a bit lame
yeah so the kalashnikov like answers
backward pawn on d6 and the square
weakness on d5 but there's also a hablar
de form
yeah this is time spent here is really
funny taking it to extremes can I do
this let's try this I don't really see
why I shouldn't okay so I managed to get
rid of this dark squared Bishop check I
should have gone to you seven home quite
often a stupid stuff just 97 Anna
completely fine now I have to sacrifice
this porn which wasn't necessary at all
white setup was very naive actually went
okay let's see 94 Queen five no it's
just completely unnecessary to that I
now have to play this kind of thing
[Music]
I have some compensation i'm not sure if
it is enough but threatening 92 now for
example bishop f1 Knight f3 and this is
blundering the rook almost there's
Bishop a4 check so let's think about
this for a moment
[Music]
interesting now to be five it would
definitely hang but don't know if this
is this is actually opening up the
complete structure here anyway yeah now
I'm overlooking those so simple museum
what's happening here actually looks c8
and then sacrifice I mean I after I have
to do this now check I know I'm giving
cafeteria but still so Queen d2
yeah it works it works for him nitey X
as a 4 or Bishop a for both moves to
work yeah okay the whole staff was
really black resin I'd really really
awful to lose against the set up after
something 997 white said absolutely
White has absolutely nothing and can it
this is actually trickier I mean I this
is not bad per se just completely
unnecessary there to get into it and
then I simply overlooked this really
thought I could take Ozzie one year yeah
b5 and now he takes that that's really
losing other moves are still not easy
because Vice position is so extremely
awkward so like here and something like
that it's still kind of interesting
again yeah white setup is just not good
yeah I'm not very not i'm not very
focused this is the thing i just did not
see that he can take it and then c1 is
covered and I've lost him cannot do
anything here I think whatever he felt
so what he played here with 195 and so
on this is just getting to absolutely
nothing if I just also play in normal
move because I've got to trade the dark
squared bishop and I have firm good
control here form yeah absolutely no
problem in this position d 4 is just as
weakness as d fibers and this way you
cannot pressure-wise black at all you
can so blunder stuff like added okay